هذه هي وزاره التربيه والتوجيه بجنوب
دارفور تم الاعتداء عليها تماما وتم تدمير
كل المكاتب والاقسام الخاصه بالامتحانات
والخاصه بعمل التربيه والتوجيه هنا في
جنوب دارفور جنوب دارفور فيها تتم طباعه
جميع الامتحانات لاقليم دارفور تم تدمير
كامل لجميع ماكينات الطباعه في هذه
الوزاره كما تم نهب جميع الاجسام داخل هذه
الوزاره دمار كبير للبنيه التحتيه
والتربويه والتعليميه في جنوب دارفور
يحتاج العمل لاعاده هذا المكان الى وقت
طويل الخسائر لا حصر لها حتى الان تواصل
اللجان عملها لحصر الخسائر المتعلقه
بعمليات السلب والنهب داخل الوزارات
المختلفه ايضا تم نهب وزاره الماليه
بالولايه ومراكز تتبع للصحه مثل الصحه
الايجابيه ومركز التحصين ووزاره الصحه
وغيرها من المرافق الحكوميه الهامه في
جنوب دارفور لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات